republican governor from georgia brian
kim good morning governor thanks for
being here governor
hey good morning guys good morning all
right we want to share with you this we
want to get your
take on this governor while we have you
this morning xavier becerra head of hhs
is walking back some comments that he
made yesterday first on cnn
he said the government absolutely has a
right to know who
is and is not vaccinated here's what he
had to say yesterday that he has since
begun to reel back in
first his comments
the federal government has had it spent
trillions of dollars to try to keep
americans alive during this pandemic so
it is absolutely the govern
government's business we want to give
people a sense that they have a freedom
to choose
but we hope they choose to live we hope
people make the right choices we want
them to have the right information
but we are america we try to give people
as much freedom and choice as possible
but clearly when over 600 000 americans
have died
the best choice is to get vaccinated
what everyone hears their governor's him
saying we want to give people the sense
that they have the freedom to choose
and the government the government
definitely has the right to know whether
or
not
you are vaccinated what's your what's
your reaction
well listen i think that's the wrong
approach especially right now in the
pandemic with mixed messages that have
been coming out of washington lately
on a lot of things including the
vaccines
you know i think the people that haven't
gotten vaccinated just don't have a lot
of trust
in the government and i certainly
understand that what i've been
telling people is we don't need a
government mandate we need people to
talk to your doctor talk to the folks at
your hospital
ask them you know of covet patients that
are coming in
now are they vaccinated or not do you
think the vaccine
is helping ask your doctor that ask your
local pharmacy that
ask your family members that have been
vaccinated or your faith leaders or
other people we don't need a
you know a tyrant in government that's
going to go around and do this that
scares people i think it personally runs
them off
from trusting the vaccine so that's my
message back to him
especially when he changes his tune
originally saying it's absolutely
the government's business and then he
tweeted out later in the day yesterday
afternoon
some comments i made today are being
taken wildly out of context to be clear
government has no database tracking who
is vaccinated
we're encouraging people to to step up
to protect themselves
uh and others by getting vaccinated it's
the best way to save lives
and end this pandemic is that why you
think people don't trust the government
they say one thing
we know what they actually mean but then
they correct it later
oh no no doubt about it lots of mixed
messages out there
we're not going to be tracking anybody
in the state of georgia
and you know my whole family's been
vaccinated i feel very comfortable with
that but that's an individual choice
especially for the people that
are left that have not been vaccinated
they've got to get comfortable
uh making that health care decision for
themselves and i believe that they can
do that if they'll simply take a few
minutes and talk to their
medical professionals right i don't
start giving medical advice all of a
sudden i'd say i got vaccinated and
you could take for that what you want
it's up to you i might choose to go
cliff diving i don't want people to tell
me i can't
meanwhile dr jonathan reiner has a
different take on that governor listen
to this
i do think it's time to start mandating
vaccines
and i think that private industry and
private organizations will do that
75 million adults have chosen not to get
vaccinated
and that choice has consequences now we
can't force you to take a jab in the arm
but there are many jobs perhaps
that can prevent you from working if you
decide not to get vaccinated
you comfortable with that no listen
that's a decision that i believe
individuals need to make private
employers need to make
i don't always agree with those
decisions but i've always been
consistent we don't need the government
mandating these things
on a person or a private business i've
been a small business owner for 35 years
i don't want the government telling me
you know whether i need to vaccinate my
employees or not
i just don't think we need to be in that
business i think if you see that happen
you're going to see
people revolt you know like they've been
doing on airplanes on
whether to wear a mass now or not and
people are fighting over that i can't
imagine what it would be like if we
start doing something like that with
vaccines
they start making k-12 where uh get
vaccinated there's going to be a war
there
i hope you'll forgive me for a little
bit of a wind-up here but governor i've
been watching this documentary on one of
the most influential people of the 20th
century edward bernays he's kind of the
godfather of propaganda and pr
it's how you control people's choices
through manipulation through propaganda
this vaccine effort is part of that
push to control what choices we make
it's also how you push a message
vice president kamala harris suggests
democrats are going to invest 25 million
dollars in painting
republican laws like your georgia law to
increase voter integrity
as voter suppression this is a full-on
push a propaganda push and you know this
very well because it's been somewhat
successful
a push to characterize your law i want
you to listen to
vice president kamala harris very
quickly on this new push
in 2020 you were heard america
you were heard loud and clear
but there is another side to this story
so far this year 17
state legislatures have enacted 28
new laws that will make it harder for
americans to vote
these bills now be clear but enacted
these bills have already become law
they are now on the books this all
is designed i believe to make it
harder for you to vote
so that you don't vote so make it harder
for you to vote
call it voter suppression call it racist
governor you're in a propaganda war
how do you win this hey we gotta fight
like hell
that's what i've been telling people we
have the truth on our side
now the vice president's lying like the
president has been about georgia's law
uh we actually add the amount of days
that people can vote
early on the weekends in the state of
georgia we've got many more
opportunities for people to vote early
than
president biden's own state of delaware
and a lot of other states where the
democrats are in control
they're just not being truthful to
people and listen this is just part of
their playbook
their legislation failed at congress to
have a federal takeover
of elections which is unconstitutional
now they have the department of justice
when we have
you know violent crime killings in major
cities all over the country a crisis at
the border
and the fight they're picking is suing
us over our elections integrity act
and they realize now after the arizona
ruling that's not going to work so now
they're moving to the democratic party
at the national level trying to spend 25
million dollars
to cancel us but my message is look
we're going to stand up and fight we
have the truth on our side
but you need to be aware they're going
to try to cancel you
they're going to try to boycott your
business move your ball game just like
they did
the all-star game in georgia they're
going to come after your way of life
this isn't a fight just in georgia
this is a nationwide fight it is one
worth fighting
and that is what i'm going to continue
to do yeah and the propaganda worked
it it it influenced major league
baseball to pull their game as you
mentioned out of georgia
and part of that fight back clearly as
you guys have put together
an ad slamming major league baseball for
that decision let's take a look at the
ad really quickly
this week we should be celebrating
baseball
instead stacey abrams and the liberal
mob forced the all-star game to move
despite the fact that we made it easier
to vote
so governor we want to talk about crime
which is an issue that
i know your folks are really worried
about atlanta area especially
and then right outside of atlanta
kennesaw georgia the golf pro was killed
on the golf course
and i know someone who lives on that
golf course and he said the golf pro
actually lives there
he has two little kids there's a
memorial for him crime is going up
everywhere how do you
how is governor can you combat this
well first of all our thoughts and
prayers go out to the siller family i
mean that is just a tragic
event wrong place at the wrong time to a
good man
and a great family and we'll continue to
have them our prayers i appreciate the
cobb county police department
chief cox for getting this terrible
person off the streets to protect all
jordans and other people around the
country
but look this is happening in major
cities number one because we don't have
uh the democrats supporting local law
enforcement and standing shoulder to
shoulder and behind them to back them up
putting boots on the ground works i got
so fed up with this
almost three months ago now i asked
colonel wright with the georgia state
patrol to come up with a plan
to help us assist the atlanta police
department
they are working with their hands tied
behind their back but they are doing
everything they can to support us
we have made a lot of headway going
after street racers
violent criminals the speaker ralston
and the georgia general assembly right
now
holding hearings to see what else we can
do
not only to support law enforcement but
to better go after his estate these
individuals
when local governments won't do that and
we also passed a bill this year
to keep rogue local governments from
defunding the police we've got to stand
with our law enforcement
personnel and take the fight to these
individuals and show them that we're not
going to put up with this
we also have to hold those bad actors
accountable which we should do
and that's exactly what we're going to
do in georgia and that's uh is so so
typical of
it seems like states are at war with
their own cities uh how do you feel
about buckheads spinning out and trying
to get their
independence from atlanta and have their
own police force are you supporting that
well that's certainly uh you know going
to be an interesting
fight there if you will the studies are
going on now there's a group that's very
passionate about that
there's a lot of things to consider
there which i certainly will do
and see where the legislature ends up on
that but the fact of the matter is i
understand why they're doing it
they're fed up i mean just two nights
ago there was somebody that was
literally blocked from the governor's
mansion in the heart of buckhead
doing home invasions i was at
had breakfast with a group the other day
at an establishment up the street from
the governor's mansion
they have armed security guards two of
them in the parking lots they've had so
many cars broken into
and stolen and other things i mean
people are fed up they're outraged but
even worse they are scared and they want
something done
and i think they're sending that message
to the mayor and the city of atlanta
that they demand that and that's what
the
campaign for the mayor's race this year
is going to be about in the city of
atlanta
we also want to ask you about tropical
storm elsa i know that 10 were injured
in georgia at a navy base what's the
latest on that
yeah we got listen we had a uh just a
really spotty storm that hit uh king's
bay down there
thankfully no one uh had loss of life as
of yet there is one critically injured
person the rest of them were
i think fairly minor injuries which is a
blessing and our prayers go out to all
those that have been affected not only
here but in the state of florida
as well but we've got a lot of state
resources down there helping clearing
roads the power companies have made
great headway getting
power restored and all in all compared
to what happened in florida we got very
lucky the other night in georgia but we
have a lot of folks on the ground
responding as we speak
all right governor brian kemp of georgia
we appreciate your time and perspective
this morning
thank you thanks guys have a great day
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now